not to jump the gun but you may be
talking about this later on another
thing but the taking the road warrior
trip down to Common Ground
was that unbelievable
[Applause]
that was our first year at Comic-Con and
you know Mad Max was that just really
weird movies ever right that was so good
and what's the character that Conan
played uh it was one of my warrior
that's one of my favorite scenes in that
movie that in Mad Max the this Caravans
were running down and then the camera
just comes down and it pivots around and
reveals
that guy in the front played that I was
just like okay this might be the
greatest with a flame throwing guitar
yes so wearing long johns and Conan was
like I want to play him and they were
like oh my God yes that was the perfect
opening it was great for that year
especially and also I think that was the
first trip to the Comic-Con yes and yeah
exactly yeah that was perfect then we
set up we had to do that we had to match
that energy every year yeah right
oh I know that was hard to I mean I
showed that in writer's rooms on that's
a good one yeah it was like
because the filmmaking was it was cool
yeah it was beautifully shot those were
the only things we ever I mean we didn't
we sometimes in other remotes would um I
think that was the most expensive thing
the show's ever done well the Mad Max
yes our designer our special effects guy
um just literally
re-constructed that that that giant
vehicle we had a parking lot on the
Warren brothers lot where we had a a
crane and we just assembled the thing it
was a four day project
[Music]
he built the flamethrower guitar every
and I think was over it was a lot of
them how much are we talking dude 100
000 okay okay can I talk about a weird
fave from that originated in Robert's
era which was the ventriloquist dummy
choir do you remember that bit Robert
yeah of course was that in a remote no
no no no
this is where I got you recurring
you've fallen into my trap
which is that it was a hilarious Studio
bit that was that Dino yes Dino had an
official idea for the ventriloquist
dummy choir and Dino stamatopoulos and
it was just you know for nobody's ever
seen it it was ventriloquist they did it
I think first at Christmas and they're
singing the Hallelujah Chorus and these
doughy guys with garish yellow choir
robes and their dummies and little
matching Green Fire Road singing the
Hallelujah Chorus from the Messiah yeah
really funny a Hungarian television
producer when I was head writer fell in
love with the ventriloquist dummy choir
and flew them over to appear on a
Hungarian talk show
Brian McCann accompanied them Brian
McCann one of our Mainstay writers for
years yeah and character actor on the
show and he had to take these guys who
were kind of you can imagine like
middle-aged men who are ventriloquist
sir maybe not
Dream Team to go to Eastern Europe right
at the time but it was a really really
from what it was it reminded me of like
when you talked about surrender on that
on that um using that big like a big
song and a remote can really or in Mad
Max one too like big track because
because McCann cut it up with uh
we're an American band yeah so there's
all these shots of these idiots walking
through Budapest withholding their
ventriloquist dummies and like trying to
do touristy stuff and there's like we're
an American band and it was real dad
really funny yeah I think they drove
them nuts because some of them were
trying to get lined they were all like
this is my big break yeah I tried to get
McCann on the phone before we did this
to like get a a memory of it but at some
point you'll have them on again or
whatever I talked about it but it was I
think he was worn out by these idiots
right